throughout history it's been rare for a
country to request to be annexed
it's even rarer for the answer to that
question to be no
but when the mongolian people's republic
asked the ussr several times to be
incorporated into it the answer was
always that
which raises the obvious question why
why did the ussr refuse to annex
mongolia
first it should be noted just how an
independent mongolia came to be
and the ussr's role in that as many of
you will know mongolia was a part of
china under the qing dynasty
that was until at all to use a technical
term went to hell and mongolia declared
its independence in 1911.
it was briefly reincorporated into the
new republic of china in 1919 before
declaring its independence again two
years later
at this point the russian civil war was
well underway and it soon spilled over
into mongolia and it was occupied by
communist troops
now the new ussr did agree with the
chinese that mongolia was still a
rightful part of china
after a series of talks in 1924 the
soviets agreed to withdraw
but the timetable for this would be set
at another meeting except for one issue
the ussr was now under new mustachioed
leadership who simply opted to postpone
the meeting to monday the 4th of never
and then created a communist government
in mongolia
from its inception communist mongolia
was a soviet puppet state
however unlike its neighbor to the north
the tuvan people's republic mongolia
wasn't annexed into the ussr
and the primary reason for this was to
avoid war both with china and also japan
from 1952 onwards mongolia was ruled by
a man called yum jaglin zeddenbol
look i'm not even gonna pretend that
pronunciation was any good sedenbaal
over the course of his premiership
asked to be incorporated into the ussr
at least six times
and each and every time the answer was
no so why
well it was down to the fact that the
ussr could get everything it wanted from
mongolia without any sort of negatives
that would come from annexing it
also when you look at all of the states
that the ussr did annex they were by and
large all former parts of the russian
empire and annexing states from outside
of these borders wasn't something any
soviet leaders were interested in
largely because the ussr wanted to
cultivate an international reputation of
being anti-imperialist and pinching
neighbours didn't fit with that
mongolia's economy had largely been
built by the ussr to serve the needs of
moscow
and mongolia was incorporated into the
soviet economy nearly to the same extent
as say kazakhstan or uzbekistan
it's just that having it as a nominally
independent nation would spare the upset
of the ussr's valuable chinese allies to
the south
and also it was a card that the ussr
always wanted to hold in case it needed
diplomatic leverage with the chinese
theoretically the status of mongolia
could always be settled at a later date
and always in china's favor if the right
situation ever arose
which is why despite mongolia's asking
the ussr always refused to annex it
mongolia was already giving it
everything that it wanted
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker danny
maloney marvin cassell the pastry
section rob waterhouse
mo aaron the white james castaneda
jordan longley gustav swann marcus
asner jerry lamdin rasheed ali cooling
castleman spilling three plates david
silverman maggie paxkowski coppertone
izzy spencer lightfoot phobojo matthew
shipley
robert wetzel lexy schwinn and winston k
wood